facebook's independent oversight board
will decide this morning if former
president trump will be allowed to
return to the site
facebook and other social media
platforms banned mr trump after his
fiery speech to supporters on january 6
a speech that was followed
by the assault on the u.s capitol that
left five people dead
nancy cordes is at the white house for
us following all of this
nancy what are the stakes here well tony
the board's decision
is binding so this will determine
whether
the former president gets his tech
megaphone back at least
on facebook but keep in mind this board
is looking
not at the entirety of his posts on
facebook over
many years but on a single post on
january 6
that facebook executives said incited
violence
these are the people who will decide the
former president's facebook fate
they are human rights lawyers
constitutional law experts
even a nobel peace prize winner and the
former prime minister of denmark
and we fight we fight like hell
they will determine if mr trump really
did violate
facebook's rules on january 6 when
with the capitol under siege he posted
these are the things and events that
happen
when a sacred landslide election victory
is so
unceremoniously and viciously stripped
away
facebook accused him of inciting
violence and said
the risks of allowing the president to
continue to use our service
during this period are simply too great
mr trump's banishment on facebook
twitter
and youtube prompted an outcry on the
right
florida's republican legislature passed
a bill that would
fine social media companies for
deplatforming
political candidates governments this is
about protecting our constituents
and our citizens and ensuring that they
are not censored or canceled and mr
trump himself
could get a second chance if facebook's
new
oversight board decides in his favor
board was created to give the public
some trust that an independent group
was making these crucial decisions nick
thompson is ceo
of the atlantic number one they have
overturned facebook decisions
significantly more frequently than they
have upheld them secondly
they can decide with principles of free
speech
looking at those data points what might
come to the conclusion
that their likely ruling today is that
the ban will be lifted
despite his banishment from social media
mr trump
continues to push the falsehood that the
election was somehow
stolen from him he made the claim again
this week
in a new blog on his website where
supporters can guess what anthony share
those posts to
facebook and twitter if they like them
all right we'll see what facebook does
nancy thank you